animal crossing New Horizons is the game
that keeps on giving and that means we
have a handful of extra tips just for
you let's get to it
the ladder if you've been playing Animal
Crossing for a couple days now you might
be wondering how you climb up cliffs in
order to do that you'll need the
collapsible ladder which Tom Nook will
give you once you meet a few conditions
you'll need to pay off your first loan
to Tom Nook and upgrade to a house which
will then allow you to build nook's
cranny on the de nooks cranny opens Tom
Nook will give you access to the ladder
or you could just have a friend give one
to you
rocks regenerate don't like where a rock
is no problem
eat a piece of fruit and smash it with
your shovel the next day a new rock will
respond somewhere else on your island
just make sure you mind the rock of its
resources before you break it how to add
best friends when you visit a friends
island or a friend visits you over the
internet you can add them as a best
friend to do that open your Nook phone
scroll over to the best friends app and
you should be able to send a friend
request from there the benefits to
registering a friend as a best friend is
that you can use all your tools on their
Island you can send gifts and letters
and you can send messages to each other
with your Nook phone fishing tips if
you're a completionist you might have
your sights set on the cast master
challenge that requires you to catch a
hundred fish in a row it may seem
daunting but we have an odd tip that
could help you out if you are struggling
to catch fish we recommend plugging in
headphones and using your hearing to
catch a fish instead when you cast your
line in a fish nibbles close your eyes
when the fish finally bites you'll hear
a plunk press a right away to reel in
the fish this may not work for everyone
but it has helped a few of us complete
that challenge how to move your house
and other buildings unhappy with where
you built your Museum no problem once
you've unlocked the residence services
building you can move your house your
villagers houses and other key buildings
by talking to Tom Nook about
infrastructure keep in mind that you can
only move one building per day and it
can be pricey
how amiibo work amiibo and amiibo cards
have a couple of functions and Animal
Crossing new horizons first once you've
unlocked harves island you can scan your
amiibo and have characters pose for
pictures second once you unlock the
campsite and your first camper has moved
in you'll unlock the ability to scan and
villagers at the Nook stop machine using
amiibo they will show up on your island
instantaneously but you aren't
guaranteed to get them to move in right
away how to get the able sisters one of
the random visitors who can come to your
Island is Mabel a hedgehog who sells
clothes she's hoping to set up a store
but needs to establish some customers
first and that's where you come in buy a
bunch of her stuff and pretty soon
she'll ask to set up shop
unlike nook's cranny you don't have to
supply any materials talk to sable
everyday Mabel and her sister sable
operate the able sisters tailor shop
sable is the quieter one in the back and
at first she won't have much to say to
you but as you talk to her every single
day she'll eventually open up and even
give you gifts how to unlock Island
terraforming if you watch the Nintendo
Direct you might be wondering how and
when you get the island designer app
that lets you terraform and further
customize your island I don't want to
spoil too much here but basically you
have to roll credits this means that you
should continue to help out Tom Nook
until he achieves his personal dream
after you've done that he'll swing by
your house and give you the island
designer app right from the get-go
you'll be able to start building paths
but if you want to terraform your island
you'll need to use your nook miles at
the nuke stop machine to unlock permits
for both water scaping and cliff
building if there's anything we missed
please let us know in the comments below
and be sure to check out our other tips
videos here on YouTube or gamespot.com
thank you so much for watching
[Music]